I want to start with an appetizer
obviously we're going to talk about
gains that you should know by heart and
you're not gonna regret it so I'm happy
to see familiar faces but today's menu
will start an appetizer and the second
will be the main course which will
feature a tenon now although a rivers
were reversed then and now namely a game
by Kamsky and none other than Bobby
Fischer let's get started so this game
is as a puzzle I'll flip the board and
it's known if you realize it that
Johannes Berg cooked sister which
wouldn't fit on the screen
is not an actual name it's a protest
League team fighting against Norvig
gnomes because recently instead of the
US chess league now we have protest
league so I decided to bring some
appetizers and some little puzzles from
those matches and I'd invite the
audience and you who watch watches to
find it the solution right here so I'm
gonna give four examples of this process
League and four highlight puzzles from
that event this one was played I'm not
sure who white was but I know that the
player from Norway gnomes was none other
than hammer not MC Hammer but the second
of Magnus Carlsen and he is well known
to win sometimes and this was the same
occasion he didn't find the winning move
but I'm sure the audience here who I see
many familiar faces
can tell me what the solution might be
black to move and when
it's noticeable that the White King is
kind of stuck in the corner so that
might have to do something with the
solution what's the idea
you said that rook takes f3 mm-hmm with
the idea of mm-hmm and what solutions
you see for white
how could he defend against we should be
for
yeah he has none you saw that Luke takes
f3 as suggested by the audience young
member on the audience is a brilliant
idea that MC I mean sorry hammer missed
and Queen takes f3 cream b1 and even
though white would like to run he just
cannot hide and Bishop b4 as let's say
Knight will play F Knight f4 Bishop b4
and it's goodbye time for white as the
queen is lost another solution I saw was
maybe Queen e5 with an option and if
Knight f4 then the same idea of Bishop
e4 and that's winning but and I mean
hammer won the game anyways but this
would have been a nice finish also there
was this game played by the New Jersey
knockouts versus the Montclair Sopranos
and black seemingly has an overwhelming
advantage as he has a strong passer and
also the chance of winning a whole rook
but what actually white didn't see that
he's not lost what could have the New
Jersey knockouts play here and would
have actually changed the final result
of the match that was really close
and was won by Montclair some pro knows
black is lost dad lost not just lost in
any position where you're looking for
tactics always look for something called
mate and even though it might not be
apparent at the first look it's always a
good idea to imagine if I would if I
could just put a rook there
maybe that would be a mate on the board
so first try to imagine it dear viewer
and then you might actually find a
solution
rook h4 yes that's an idea and where's
the other place you could put it ruk age
4 would run into Queen d5 check
unfortunately rubgy six again check on
d5 and actually with GC yes rook rook g5
actually this would allow a beautiful
tactic by black it's black to move thank
thank you for the suggestion
because now black would have a wonderful
tactical idea obviously rook takes F two
wins at the spot so I apologize but
Queen takes g2 is an interesting idea as
if Queen takes then rook f1 check and
Queen G fun rook takes g1 and this is
winning for black and there's no other
way to avoid this so yes indeed rook g5
is the move which is pretty brilliant
because rook takes f2 doesn't work
because it's made in one but what if
black can check on d5 because rook takes
on d5 and the same mate happens but what
if Queen f7 how could why proceed in
this position mm-hmm Queen takes Queen
takes rook takes and made beautiful mate
unfortunately mess by white
so this is the game between Dallas
destiny and Rio Grande ospreys so don't
forget these are approaches League teams
actually duking it out to make it to the
playoffs and then it will be just
straight matches till one of them
qualifies into the finals so here black
is in a troubled situation
so what could how could white try and
break through okay that's the first move
is was a given but I'd be happy to see
and hear the ideas behind it so it's
obviously rook takes f7 so black has no
choice but to take it how should I
proceed in this position
yep and I check and black plate king e8
but how could my proceed if black plays
for example King g8
yeah Queen e6 check yeah King h8 would
run to knight of seven and we take your
queen king g7 yeah Queen f7 King age six
pin takes King takes Knight check King
f5 I suspect mate I don't know maybe
it's my sixth sense but I think it's
made in one here but please yeah Misha
page three mates and that's a goodbye
kiss from this beautiful Bishop on g2
but Rio Grande player didn't go that way
he went
King e8 and running for his life which
eventually wasn't saved but it still was
the best try in this position so how
should white continue obviously why does
need to stay aggressive in this position
if he wants to stay afloat and win the
game
yeah Queen e6 would win a piece but now
the Dallas player who knows that it's
his destiny to win this game he wants to
step it up and win at all costs and
without any trouble Queen e6 black would
most probably play Queen e7 and it will
take some time for white to win the game
but I found an even stronger move here
Knight to Knight to e6 yes what's the
idea with oh he took first but then 96
exactly well what's the idea of between
496 mm-hmm and also yeah attacking the
Queen and also just having a monster
night on e6 that big octopus as Eric
Rosen would say is just suffocating
black and Bishop takes c6 doesn't work
obviously because why it would just take
Queen e7 and just takes takes Bishop
takes h8 and my this bunch of pieces up
and should win easily instead like
between d6
which ran into what move yeah because
Queen can black take ya then and I just
I just Forks and white means immediately
so black had to take the sorry choice of
route k7 and in these positions when you
won back the material there is a good a
good point of trying to stabilize the
situation you already gained what you
came for
so you might as well stabilize what kind
of move could stabilize White's
advantage actually rook f1 was played
but now I decided to stabilize it which
which move with which move a stabilizing
move something that protects our pieces
c4 exactly a very good move as
unfortunately Queen h4 would run into
trouble because black can't take and we
would try to give the check but all that
Brooke just takes us so if we would try
to take back the bishop that would be
two other problems namely that they will
take the knight so c4 is a good
stabilizing move making sure that why
is winning Queen age for his more
adventurous and could lead to trouble
so in this position just stabilizing the
situation is important because it's a
team tournament if you're winning you're
supposed to win it if you don't win a
winning position that could put a lot of
burden on your team so C 4 is
exclamation exclamation exclamation
point Ruki 7 rook f6 Queen d7 Queen h4
check in g2 and how can black try to
defend till his last breath
mm-hmm yeah I woke up seven and this
unfortunately ends because of so
obviously he had to take and this was
the best move by far been f7 but then
mates and d8 so nobody could avoid their
destiny in this game so there was there
are other regions playing in this
tournament and these regions are not
just America it's the whole world
it's the protest League and the whole
world is playing so obviously the famous
Ryder was inclined to play and his name
is Gorky and I don't know why he's a
storm bringer but it was his choice
so because the whole world plays even
the nomads are playing in this
tournament
so if he ran black player came up with a
brilliant solution which greatly
reminded me of Zoe's game versus rapport
mine mind me
Wesley's leading and he's in the lathe
in the tata steel chess tournament so
that's a great result so it's black to
move and find an amazing combination who
owns the center
who has more pawns in the center black
so if anyone loves limb biscuit but I
don't know if that's the case we would
like to roll it roll it roll it so I
guess to be able to roll it you need
some skateboards and if you don't have a
skateboard well just buy one that's
simple
d5 doesn't work because the knight
annoyingly takes our pawn on e5 but
that's the first step finding the
solution so d5 doesn't work because of
these pieces attacking the e5 on so how
can we possibly start rolling our palms
exactly rook takes c4 rook takes e4
Bishop takes c4 we should take spawn we
should be f1 if we are attacking would
be one more exchanges now we wouldn't so
what should we play here
yeah Bishop f3 is a good move but black
decided to go Bishop b7 and white being
from the schmick and no mods
he started out attacking like crazy and
if you remember the so vastly rough
board game you'll find the move here
because it has the same idea that should
have been played in that game so that's
a hint
so black to play and win a six and what
if we want to go a bit more Rambo with
it yeah Rambo of course Rambo so
whenever we think about in pawn pushes
and aggressive moves we should play like
Robert aggressively forward and as far
as we can push it so no not a six but a
five so B takes a six happened in the
game which overlooked something that
would have been even be deadly if Robert
would play it or you will play it it's
black to move and Gavin and spilt
winning for black
yeah that's that's a sneaky check that
ends the game immediately so I can give
away as many pieces as he'd like but
that wouldn't stop the position from
being a mate yes but that would take the
pawn and there's such a big attack going
on for example for example just to prove
a point Queen d2 Queen b6 Queen f2 takes
takes e4 and I promised I promised
everybody that black will start rolling
the pawns and we'll go a 4d v e5 d 4 and
wouldn't stop until promotion so this
idea of sacrificing the rook on c4 was
actually a sound idea even if you check
it with stock fish or any computer if
you check it with any computer it's
still a great idea I approved
so we marched for appetizers from the
games of the protest League so it's time
to have our main meal and main course
and the den and now section starts now
so I want to start with a reverse then
and now namely this game played by
Chomsky I've played calm ski he's a good
player and trust me on that
it was tough playing him he beat me but
it was fun it was a fun long game
so efore was played as Chomsky played in
2009 against Apollo with the same idea
which we will soon see this is which
opening if I could ask Villa PES yes
the Spanish and in in the right hands
it's a Spanish torture it should be 7 b5
b6 so no no marshals today and I guess
no marshals tomorrow
these 6c three castles d4 and if you
know calm ski and of course you do
because you love chess you'd know what
he play here push d5
he likes these strategic positions and
d5 is just an open invitation to a good
old strategic game Knight a5 Bishop C to
C 6 H 3 bishop heads back to c8 d takes
c6 Knight takes c6 Knight d2 where is
the white knight headed yeah 2 F 1 and G
2 9 f 1 and Knight g3 and actually
that's what happens aged 6 9 f 1 this
should be 6 9 g 3 Ruki 8 and chomsky
surprisingly knows about about alekhine
and knows that if possible play on two
sides and that's what he does so what
did Kamsky play here
a for of course a for Queen c7 9 H for
and his opponent is playing pretty well
because he also knows the basic
principles of chess and figured that hmm
my opponent is playing on the flanks
where should I play now
why should he play now Center of course
d5 he takes d5 Bishop takes d5 Knight h5
rook b8 and now if you're a grandmaster
and if you're a super grandmaster as
Kamsky you would know what moves to play
here
it's a stone-cold move but it's very
cool what was that oh not not yet well
Brooks like open lines so a takes b5 and
before we would go crazy and take on g2
Tomsky would point out that after Queen
e2 he will win a piece and that's not a
good omen against the Grandmaster nor
against anybody to be a piece down so he
took back the pawn and thought that oh I
have a decent position but this is the
moment when lightning struck what
happened
come ski to move and win yeah Bishop
takes h6 Bravo very good G takes 86 and
how should white continue mm-hmm it's
not the best
when you're attacking it's a good idea
to bring more and more pieces to the
attack because it's basic math if you
can outnumber your opponent with your
pieces most likely it's gonna be made
exactly Queens c1 brilliant brilliant
move what's the point behind queen c1
[Music]
yeah it yeah white decides to keep black
uncertain I might take with the Queen on
eight six or with the night I don't know
maybe but most likely the problem is for
black now that the queen is coming to
the attack with full force and there's
actually no way to defend Bishop f8
trying to fend off the attack but that
does not deter Chomsky from attacking
knight Knight takes h6 check and if
Bishop takes h6 th8 was played but if
instead Bishop takes h6 Queen takes h6
and what happens if cook rook d69 f5 and
the Queen g7 mate is unstoppable
and if rookie six then there comes a
brilliant line obviously Knight f5 98
and again like to move and just when
actually not just when Nate 97 if I take
with the Queen how am I waited
yeah Queen 8:7 King f8 Queen h8 mate
the others square so not night at 5:00
at night eh five actually putting so
much pressure on apps --tx this poor
night cannot define g8 any longer
because Bishop takes h6 will just lose
to Queen takes h6 98 and I take SEP six
work the except six but this is Queen g8
mate so this is a game you should know
by heart by Kamsky and the final game
was by the player known as Bobby Fischer
I think that's not anything new Bobby
Fischer played this tour in America in
1964 and played this game against chela
it's obviously not his most famous game
but I still enjoyed watching this one
Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop c4 Bishop c5
and if we know that Bobby Fischer is an
ambitious player
what would an ambitious player play in
this position o Bishop takes f7 is a bit
too aggressive Fischer is more
conservative than that yeah b4 yes who
wouldn't love the evens gambit well
actually Fischer loved the evens gambit
and was planning to play it more but
instead of him because Favre adopted it
and won plentiful games like against
Pickett and Anand check those out
they're great this should be for c3 we
should be 7 and how should I continue
d4 obviously so here the right move is
95 95 but black baby 6d takes e5 Knight
takes e5 Knight takes e5 D takes e5 and
now a move that usually never wins you a
game will win a game for Fischer that's
how good he is
what move did Fischer played here that
would never work for anyone else
almost Bishop takes f7 doesn't even work
for Fischer I'm sorry to say that Queen
h5 yes because the bishop is so
awkwardly placed on e7 that the f7 pawn
is hard to defend
so chela play g63 take c5 Knight f6 and
Fisher knows a lot about chess he knows
you have to hit the iron tell it till
it's warm I mean when it's warm so what
did he play here
no not Bishop g5 black is about to
Castle we wouldn't want that that would
make for a long game yeah that's one way
but he did he didn't play Bishop h6 he
did the other way around so he played
Bishop e3 King f8 would run into
something that would hurt a lot
that's namely Queen takes f6 and you
can't take the Queen
so Ruka fate was played castles Knight
g4 3 and g3 takes takes Queen e7 and I
don't know how big of a fan Bobby
Fischer was of basketball but he knew
how to bring new peeves pieces into play
and he did that superbly and this move
just introduces a new player in on the
bench and that is Bishop b5 check c6 and
what was the idea of Fischer
in these positions material doesn't
count as much as usual here it's good to
do something I always call abstract
logic when you're ahead in development
it's much more important to attack if
you can than to protect the pieces so if
you're an attacking player and you're
way ahead of development
just put your pieces to the most optimal
places and then we'll you will win the
game
rook the one that's a good idea but
unfortunately the knight is hanging on a
three yeah 93 to c4 yes that's what
Fischer played Queen e6 rook d1 exactly
the idea was good just you have to first
bring in the killer beasts the night
into the game and then if the pawn takes
b5 the Knight d6 check King d8 and then
as we talked about abstract logic it's
not the number of the pieces but the
activity of the pieces that counts and
rook d1 and Bishop d7 Knight takes King
c8 9 d6 and King b8 you just go and play
either rook d5 or rugby for and you just
have overwhelming compensation as the
rook on a it is very bad and White's
pieces are really active so in this
position have to complement black for
finding Queenie 6 which gives a little
space for the King so he could run away
from the 96 checks so route D 1 C takes
b5 and how did Fischer continue
96 check then the King just goes to e7
96 check ok 96 check just King e7 group
d6 would just lose the night on C farm
fortunately
when you're attacking bring an extra
piece into the attack that's always a
good yeah Queen c7 Queen c7 Bishop d7 96
check King g7 and Fisher knows that
Brooks were the best on open files yes
so how did Bobby find the right solution
here rook F e1 is a little bit slow but
the idea is similar
yes 9f5 takes takes and what's the idea
behind 9f5
mm-hmm exactly
so Queenie if I would immediately run
into rookie one and we'd say goodbye
clean but obviously black didn't want to
lose like that so he played rook c8
counter-attacking now yes rook takes
Queen takes rook e1 oh no not even
brookie one lucky one actually was
Fisher's original intention but then he
recalled Emmanuel Oscar and he said if
you see a good move there must be an
even better one so here Fischer even
played a strong even stronger move than
that mm-hmm with the idea of f6 with the
idea yes and that's what happened FF six
brilliant idea Knight f6 and now yeah
rook e1 check and now this is even
better
rook takes e4 you have six mean takes
rook f d8 queen g4 and we know how much
how precise Fischer wanted to be all the
time he loved this game and mentioned
this and talked about this game in his
sixty memorable games and in this
position he played queen g4 but as a
self-critical person he mentioned that I
should have found Queen d7 check that is
winning much much quicker
but apparently he said I forgot my king
f5 King f4 Queen g5 mate
he forgot that Emmanuel Oscar said the
same thing again that even if you find a
good move
it's always possible to find the best
one and therefore this would have been a
brilliant mate but Queen g4 was also
winning and this was Fisher's brilliancy
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]